So, here's a, an interesting example.
This is a great old slide.
I think this slide is actually from
The Psychology of Computer Vision book
by Pat Winston,
which I think was 1975, I don't know.
It's just such a cool because they,
it was before we could do any,
it's just beautiful.
Anyway, so, the idea is here
is the image on the left and
another image on the right.
And the question is taken
at time one and time two.
How are things moving?
Well if I just look at these two
pictures, it's a little hard to tell.
But if I give you the flow field,
it's very clear what's going on.
Right?
What's going on is the camera
is moving forward.
Right?
The camera is moving forward,
which is inducing this flow field.
All right?
And that's the flow field of a plane.
That's going to be a Homography.
And there is another flow field here and
you realize this thing called a Demon.
And that's whats so cute because back in
the old days in AI when you had little
list programs running
in the background and,
and, little things would run on their
own and have their own behavior.
They were called demons,
so this is a lisp joke.
Anyway, so you can see this demon is
actually just a planar cardboard thing
that is moving sort of forward and
to your right it's left.
You can see that from the flow field,
and
if you cut up this image into this area.
And then that area, you would
have two different flow fields,
both of which would be homographies.
So, they would both be modelable flow.
All right?
So, I'm going to show you
a couple different things.
Some is more math, some is, less math.
But, it's basically the mathematics
behind modeled flow.